my guest tonight very funny comedian of
course and an actor who's starring in
the film most wanted which is available
on demand beginning friday and you can
stream his new stand-up special
the pale tourist on amazon prime
also on friday please welcome coming to
us live from a
uh steakhouse i believe jim gaffigan jim
where are you what's going on
thanks so much it is great to be here
thank you for having me
conan oh for god's sake it's good to be
here i'm a big fan
of your uh show okay
there's you have it on a it says show on
a piece of paper that's the idea
says joe okay all that excuse me
okay yes all right yeah no
no just a minute no no yes
no you're talking into a zucchini yes he
is wearing the shirt of a 12 year old
boy
um we've got a lot to talk about you
we've known each other i think for over
60 years
[Music]
65 years um no
what is that is that urine in a i've jar
busy today so you
you're urinating into a jar on zoom
these are human eyeballs i forgot this
is uh
i had some dilly beans from
uh aunt marty a friend of mine who makes
uh he sent me some of these these uh
dilly beans amazing okay okay sorry gone
no no no this is all gold wait a minute
who put these
stairs here oh look at that
is it you got some stairs there
it's hard that's the laziest going
downstairs i've ever done because i
don't want to move out of my chair
and i don't have i don't have the quad
strength so i'm just gonna do it while
remaining
in a chair you know it's ridiculous how
are you
jim we've known each other as i said for
like 60 years and we've liked each other
for months
yes how are you holding up in quarantine
how are you doing old friend
there's you know i just i just want um
i'm here with my family which i i love
them dearly
and i just want i want someone to go to
bed i
i want i'm tired and nobody goes to
sleep
it used to be people would go to bed i'm
the only one that goes to bed i nap
during the day and i'm still the first
one to go to bed
i'm i'm tired yeah i uh i know you have
a very large
family uh how many people are we talking
here how many kids do you got
there are five children and
um they're just and no one sleeps no one
goes to bed no one else doesn't
sleep they're just they're not they're
like my wife
they're you know they don't need sleep
they're they want to talk they want to
do things
it's like i don't know i shouldn't have
had a family i don't know if it's too
late now but
um no there's still things you could do
um
they're not legal they're not moral
but um there's we can talk when this
interview is over there's still a way
out
remember when you told me you thought
scott peterson was a good guy
do you remember that
yeah yeah i remember going on it i
remember going on at great length
about how you said that guy who killed
his pregnant wife was a good guy and i
was yeah
i said that guy just i said he
feels like a quality quality chum he
does that's what i said
yeah do you think that was a mistake i
think i think that's wrong
okay okay so what are you doing you're
not sleeping
you've got at last count 15 kids a wife
that won't sleep you must be losing your
mind is there anything that gives you
peace during these
these strange times we're in jim i i i
spend time in my garden
that never used to happen before and
you know what i like about my garden is
my family's not there
that's that's what i like about my
garden hold on it's really sweet
hello okay now yeah the interviews
it's i don't know how long i'm just i'm
just phoning it in don't worry i'll be
done
okay i love you too um
the zucchini bit is this this is
something i always go to it
you know you're hold on hold on hold on
this is a big phone call
um hello
yeah no it's not working none of the
bets
no okay hold on what can i say something
are these these must be coming from your
garden is that right is that why you
have all these massive vegetables
yes these are and by the way do you
remember in in happy days when ralph
mouth used to say
i still got it i think i still got it
i i still got it i don't i don't got it
anymore
why would a young child be wondering if
he still
got it anyway i just i don't know i
don't know how to answer that question
because i just noticed
that they put makeup on my face but i'm
wearing a short sleeve
shirt and they didn't touch my arms and
the disparity
is shocking between my face and my arm
this is a clown show here i'm in an
abandoned theater
uh and i look like lorenzo llamas
except my arms look like they've had
chemotherapy i don't know what's
happening
and i apologize and you're in a steak
restaurant or some kind of i'm in a
steak house
and when wilmer valderrama gets
finds out you took his shirt he's going
to be upset
okay okay you win you win um
what are you doing are you trying to
stay uh in shape during quarantine
i struggle for a lot of people i uh i've
uh been i've given up bread well kind of
i've i've been trying to eat healthy and
my wife bought me a scale
oh you know she loves me
you know she bought me a scale and so i
tried the scale and it's like one of
those where it works on your phone and
it keeps track of how fat you get and so
i stood on the scale and i looked at the
app and it's
it's in metric because the whole world
is in metric but it was like really
small type and i was with my
16 year old and there was this red line
and i was like did
does that say finished you know and my
uh 16 year old goes no it says obese
so you got an obese rating i'm obese
okay well you know what i would say is
just just
turn off the phone or delete the app
that's
one way that's not necessarily bad
right um
no it's not necessarily bad it's not the
best
obese can mean it's a health risk you
got to take care of yourself jim
people are counting on you oh god who's
calling you
it was it was it was no one okay just
quickly i'm getting something here
yellow yeah conan
yes i can yes jim jim um
talking through into the vegetables it
was fun the first time
the second time third time it started to
work in
um now it's really it's a problem
well i think if you do it a little more
it's gonna start to get really funny
do you think this oh you know what this
one's out of batteries
you've had that mug since late the late
show right
it was called late night i know you're a
fan uh
yeah you weren't even born when i was i
was very young oh here i got a good
story
so um i went to georgetown university
and so i was doing this fundraiser in
philadelphia
and um i arrived at the fundraiser and
there was this woman
in her 30s and uh she was running the
whole
um production and she was like you went
to georgetown i went to georgetown and i
was like oh wow
there you go and so then later on i was
talking to her
and she said what year did you graduate
and i go i graduated in 88 and she said
oh my gosh
that's the year i was born
chilling right it was just brutal i'm
just an
old old zucchini holder
you know i get this a lot like a 17 year
old kid will come up to me and go like
oh my god i can't believe it's you conan
it's so amazing can i get a selfie this
is back when you could take selfies and
i'd be like
yeah you seem excited and you went well
my grandmother watched you when she was
a little girl
that's what i get my grandmother watched
you when she was a little little girl
just off the boat from italy in the
1920s that's what i get
no it's brutal it's terribly brutal
um have you ever get this you ever have
anyone say that you remind them a little
bit of john malkovich
because when you were when you were
talking about the garden you went
you started talking about i like my
garden and it's where i like to go
and your lips did a thing and your whole
affect became like john malkovich did
you
did you realize that i see you standing
over the grave of another dead president
no i um yes i love that movie in the
line of fire
yes well he's he's from the midwest and
i'm from the midwest
and we're i used to have a more nasally
voice
but i think it got beaten out of me no
but um
yeah john malkovich when you steal
you'll say
i mean i don't do a john malkovich
impression but but
you purse your lips in a little bit and
then there's an
accent when you say the west and it's
just
john malkovich that's so brilliant but
you know what's weird he's
yeah he's brilliant he's brilliant he's
the good yes he's the one
i wish i was talking to right well you
know what the amazing but then again
what about that
that apple tv show he's got to regret
that
anyway but um the
uh but the weird thing is john malkovich
he has a little bit of a whine
you know like do you ever sometimes
see comments where people are like oh
this guy sounds so
uh feminine like do i have an effeminate
voice i mean you have a very effeminate
voice but you already know that
like do you ever hear that do people are
like do you think you have
i never get that i have people think
that i have a
it's a little bit pitched high tenor but
they think i have a commanding sort of
jfk
affect where i'm taking us to the next
generation
yeah i've never you have a very
i'm very my binary
i i have been written but i didn't
realize i had
i didn't realize i had a feminine voice
i mean not as effeminate as yours you
know what i mean
but like uh again i think we've
established that i have a commanding
um presidential and i'm talking about
1962 is that
we'll go to the moon not because it's
easy but because it's hard
you have more of a my garden my garden
i think i'll be in my garden
like when you carry around a book
because you don't have friends do you
find the book heavy
uh it's the gutenberg bible uh it's very
heavy
it's uh it's encased in in lead to
protect it
so i'm very strong you know i'm very
strong
there's a lot of things you i mean you
you're way more talented
like you can play guitar but we're both
very goofy looking
people but we've done so well given what
we look like
i mean look at us we've done great i am
in an abandoned theater
that no one wants to be in because
they're afraid of kovid and you're at a
sizzler steakhouse
i like how they whispered sizzler like
it was a secret
poison
you know i want to ask you about
something you you're doing
drive because you are a machine i
you are one of the most prolific
comedians high voiced effeminate
comedians that i know
you are you churn it out like nobody and
it's quality stuff i say turn around
to like me go on sorry
worth the interruption but no one works
as hard as you
you're doing drive-through comedy shows
where at a time when no comedian can be
working how does that work people
driving in their cars and they sit in
their cars and watch you perform
well you know the thing you know in this
time of pandemic it's important for
people to be
safe but also uh so i've done a couple
of them
you go on stage in a parking lot and you
perform for cars you feel like
you know like you're recreating the
movie cars but it is
it's pretty surreal it's you know uh
you you can you see the people or you
just see a lot of cars
you can see some you know it's a lot of
it's you know and i did a show
marina opened for me and uh you know but
what are you gonna find out from even
the comic who goes on before you're like
what's
what's the crowd like there's a bunch of
imports you know i mean like
[Laughter]
there's some suvs there's no uh electric
cars yeah
that's fantastic very nice they're
volunteering to
recreate the experience of being stuck
in traffic
so how do they let you know
i mean can you even hear them laughing
can you hear them applauding flashlights
or b
porns like they do a polite kind of like
get out of the way if they like the joke
they're like
yeah you know kind of like move it along
or i'll run you over
they do that kind of beep and then at
the end they just lay on the horn
that's really nice i love that i think
there's something kind of inspiring
about that
that's people coming together it was
this it was a nice moment of uh
community it's nice to get feedback you
know what i mean
but it was weird you know it's kind of
like
everything's about food for me it's kind
of like if you hadn't had
ice cream for five months because of a
pandemic
and then you had to eat like non-dairy
ice cream
right right i can see it's not quite the
stand-up experience
but it's as close as you're gonna get
right now yes
i have a question for you you have your
i think you're the only comedian
with his own serious channel uh and that
is quite a that is quite an
accomplishment
this is a i i mean i congratulate you
only comic
i was i was very flattered uh they they
asked me
and i was like because you know i'm
unemployed
essentially i was like this is very
exciting i asked my manager
what you know what does it pay and he's
like nothing it pays nothing
oh um but uh it's also it gets better
apparently i was i was excited about it
and then i was talking to
i was doing press and somebody revealed
that
i'm channel 790 and do you know how many
channels there are
on uh siriusxm i don't
790. i'm 790. you're the last
channel i'm the last channel you'd think
that there'd be a channel that just gave
farm reports or something that would be
792.
you're the last channel i'm i feel like
i'm
participating in some make-a-wish thing
and i'm the beneficiary and i don't know
about it
right right you are live streaming your
family dinners
good ideas dinner dinner with the
gaffigans
and it gives us a glimpse into the
madness
of your life and i've watched this
it's crazy because you have all these
kids
at last count i think in the 20s 30s
and your wife everyone's talking at once
sometimes you're talking but sometimes
you're not talking
sometimes you just sit there and eat
your mush well you know the thing is is
it started off as this you know
thing you know nice thing to do you know
we're all
i thought we'd be in quarantine for a
couple weeks hey you know there's some
single people there's some grandparents
that are away from their kids why don't
we
do stream our dinners it'll be a nice
thing we'll do it for a couple weeks
five months later we're still doing it
and it's
it's what you know we've added a
fundraising element but like i gotta be
honest there's some nights
where i just don't want to do it kind of
like how you're handling this interview
i just kind of like don't want to do it
but i do it anyway
you know what i mean and you know how
much i get paid for that nothing
it's kind of like a satellite channel
but yeah
you get paid for this interview i mean i
think i do
i believe jeff does he get paid how much
hello how much do i get six no
yeah jim gaffigan please now i know he's
there we'll get him on the blower
no no he's on right now i'm on the other
line just
listen 600
overs you're getting over 600 dollars
for this appearance that's more than you
get from dinner with the gaffigans
that's more than you get from the
serious channel that's more than you get
from mentioning sizzler four times
that's a lot of money i think sis lives
out of business
right kind of sad
i don't think you're going to get money
from them now
what are you going to have for dinner
tomorrow tomorrow
a lean fish and some vegetables you like
the way i say lean fish
also a lean you new england people you
guys eat all those bugs from the ocean
yuck
cod i eat cod not because it's hard but
because it's easy
um let's talk about this movie most
wanted interesting role for you
uh you're playing kind of a scumbag in
this yes i play a
two-timing drug dealer again so
you know i'm guilty of being type cast
uh it's it's an amazing story it's uh it
really kind of
uh it's about a guy who was framed
because during the
the peak of the war on drugs uh they
really were looking for
uh to to bring down a kingpin so they
pinned it on this
guy in his early twenties and i'm i set
him up because i'm that kind of guy
yeah you betray you betray this person
and um um you you don't seem to have
much of a moral compass is that fair to
say
that's fair to say it's uh
and you know dealing with scumbags
um i i just you know i to prepare i just
thought of like
what would conan do okay
you've gone at me maybe 40 times in this
interview
and i've i've you know i put up with a
zucchini
i put up with the constant jabs um
it's my insecurity it's just it's just i
get nervous
i get nervous i feel like there's not
enough of me kind of like there's not
enough shirt
for you but you know i just put a shirt
on
i'm sorry i'm sorry i put a shirt on
called they need their clothes back okay
yeah guess what
uh the guy who owns your shirt called
and said he's mistaken it's not your
shirt it looks like he's living
completely
i don't think this can air you don't
have to do any of this editing do you
no no there won't be any editing i want
this to go out
just as is because i think it will
finish you in the business
it will finish you you'll be done you
know you'll be lucky to get one car in
your drive-in comedy shows
you'll be on channel 900 on sirius
we'll be talking into uh you'll be
talking into a summer root vegetable
oh don't you
[Laughter]
we have a clip here from most wanted you
want to set it up for us
yeah i play this guy in this movie
i didn't know that there was a clip okay
i don't know anything about the clip
because i was supposed to look at it on
my iphone and i didn't
i'm wearing when you're doing a zoom and
it just freezes on someone like this
[Laughter]
well anyway i
we should we should uh we have a clip
here and man is this a good clip
take a look at this clip this is jim
gaffigan uh pretty much
playing himself a two-timing soulless
drug dealing
scumbag here he is in most wanted
christ you told him ten thousand for
aquila dad you said they wanted a source
you didn't say a goddamn thing about me
going to thailand
you bought tons of heroin in thailand i
bought it over two months and i smoked
it all there
what yeah i don't know how you want me
to go to thailand i don't have any cash
i don't you're going
you're gonna find them a source do not
make me look bad in front of these
people or i will
scan you and we're back
did you like the clip it was pretty good
it was pretty good
um i felt like i remember
shooting that scene and i was like what
would
conan do you know what i mean right
if he had more clothes that fit him okay
okay okay this shirt used to fit me
and then i you know got a little jacked
but you know like there is a 13 year old
girl that's looking for her shirt right
now
and do you know what i mean
when you were putting it on and there
was a training bra inside it did you
think this might not be much
i i was suspicious i was suspicious that
maybe i should take it out
um you're right shirt's too small
the makeup's off um
yeah it's all a mess and i apologize uh
let's get to the next and final question
pale tourist where did you go
jim oh i'm sorry
where you going i'm not going anywhere
come on back
you this is the least professional
thing we've ever done the least
professional
we are both trained professionals
masters of our craft and look at you
you're just moving your head around
stop it pull yourself together we're
gonna get through this
yes okay i want to make sure i mention
pale tourist
you do stand up in other countries
obviously not possible now
during this time of kovid but
um you and i both love doing that going
to other countries
uh doing uh comedy exploring the people
in the culture
i probably do more sensitivity and
layered nuance but
you go there and do whatever it is you
do are you enjoying it
i love it i wanted to call my uh
show gym without borders
but people were like that's too similar
to doctors without borders
[Laughter]
i um no i i do love doing it
you know what i mean it's like uh you
know mine i just do stand up because i
you know i don't need to be propped up
by a group of other people i just do it
myself
but i um it's a scary assignment right
and i'd love to know what you think
uh that's unbelievable right
but no i would uh it was fun and i
and i'm disappointed because i was gonna
do latin america
yeah and uh then the coronavirus head
we've all been sidelined but
you are doing a great job i mean between
uh most wanted and of course the pale
tourist uh why don't i tell people where
they can find those most one is going to
be in theaters and on demand
friday in theaters how's it going to be
in theaters
i don't know it says it says in theaters
i think it is well it's uh
i think they play it in a movie theater
and people sit in the theater and they
watch it
okay that would that would make sense
most wanted in theaters and on demand
uh friday and the pale tourist where you
see jim
uh go and do stand-up uh
uh brilliant it's like coming without
borders but like
with you know meat you know
will be available on amazon prime video
on friday
jim um i did my best you know i
i gave you the benefit of the doubt i
extended the hand of friendship
and you swat why what do you got you got
something
you keep
but no it has been so great talking to
you
conan thank you for having me
uh our final interview my final
interview with
uh with jim gaffigan by the way bail
force i've been posting them on youtube
oh good people i'm not monetizing it no
monetize
monetize away i want you to live in a
house again
i'm tired of seeing you in a restaurant
get out i want you to get out and get a
house
okay you've got 65 mouths to feed
jim i care about you i hope your
lawsuit with john malkovich goes well
and i wish you all the best you really
are a very funny
uh sometimes petulant and cruel person
but you're one of my top 600
favorite comedians that's pretty good of
the late 90s
yeah yeah that narrows it down a lot but
thank you
jim gaffigan i salute you thank you
thank you so much
you're a good man okay